these Green Fields conceal a bloody
Battlefield and an unexpected Feud
within the Russian ranks on Friday and
Saturday gave Ukrainian forces a chance
to exploit the situation
the spokesman for Russia's defense
Ministry says the ukrainians launched at
least 10 attacks in and around back mood
during the short-lived Mutiny he says
Russian forces repelled those attacks as
well as others along the dunetsk front
the Wagner Insurrection almost emptied
Russia's front lines for at least a
while but immediately after the deal was
struck between President Vladimir Putin
and Wagner commandary of Guinea
pregosian Wagner forces headed back to
the fight alongside chichenya's ahmad's
Brigade well
at the moment our units are slowly
returning to the special military
operation Zone to continue further work
on the liberation of Marie Inca
this is drove along to go back to the
front lines after spending the day in
rostov to counter the Wagner mithini
over the past few hours there's been
several Ukrainian attacks along with
similar counter-offensives on the 1000
kilometers long Battlefield
a few kilometers away from the front
civilians are caught in the middle of
this conflict here at the kivsky
neighborhood in duniesk a young man was
killed and others injured in a Ukrainian
missile attack
I was hiding with my cat in the bathroom
the sound was horrible
the Wagner Mutiny gave Ukrainian forces
an opening whether they'll be able to
take any lasting Advantage from it
remains unclear Donetsk